huh Adnan Saeed from the serial podcast
is released from jail
now that's way too controversial for me
[Music]
hey buddy
thanks Devin and I mean that thank you
for having me be the sacrificial lamb
talking about a wildly controversial
subject that will almost certainly
result in a rational attacks on me I'm
doubling my feed Devin check the invoice
the subject of the most popular podcast
of all time is a free man the stunning
reversal in the case that inspired the
serial podcast officials have dropped
all charging as Adnan said after he
spent 23 years in prison Adnan Syed he
is a free man he walked out of a
Baltimore courthouse today Syed was
convicted of murdering hey Min Lee in
1999. this doesn't mean that he's
necessarily Innocent but the state's
attorney for Baltimore Maryland Mosby
has just announced that the state is
dropping all charges against Syed this
morning I instructed my office to
dismiss the criminal case against Adnan
Saeed following the completion of a
second round of touch DNA testing of
items that were never tested before I'm
not the syed's case was featured on the
first season of the podcast serial which
became a true crime sensation the
podcast was downloaded over 100 million
times serial inspired other podcasts
about the case several documentaries and
multiple Criminal Appeals of syed's
sentence this case is also incredibly
controversial with some people convinced
that Syed is absolutely innocent I'm
innocent red just like everybody else
here and others equally convinced that
he's an unrepentant murderer you guys
are pathetic you're idolizing a murderer
in this episode we're going to explain
how we got to the point of Syed walking
free after 23 years but we are not gonna
try and solve the case in other words
we're doing the characteristic legal
eagle thing which is annoy everyone who
has a strong opinion
it's the legal legal brand let's go back
to 1999. in 1999 hey Min Lee was an
honor student at Woodlawn High School in
Baltimore County Maryland on January
23rd of that year when she was 18 years
old Lee disappeared after leaving school
there were no witnesses to her
disappearance one month later her body
was found at Lincoln Park police
determined that she had been strangled
to death and they eventually arrested
Adnan Syed Lee's 17 year old
ex-boyfriend and charged him with murder
Syed was also an honor student but
during the trial prosecutors made
hundreds of references to adnan's race
and religion introducing him to the jury
by saying the defendant is of Pakistani
background he's a Muslim now this was
used to explain the religious and
familial tensions that ultimately led to
the breakup between Lee and Syed and
hence a motive to kill but it's not a
great look what we've got here is
failure to communicate at the time of
trial there was no DNA evidence linking
Syed to the murder instead the state
relied mostly on the testimony of Jay
Wilds a friend of syeds who was a known
drug dealer Wilds was a year older than
Lee and Syed and graduated the year
before he eventually told the police
that Syed killed Lee Wilds allegedly
drove to the park where he watched Syed
Barry Lee's body here's the basic
version of events the prosecution
presented during the trial around
lunchtime on the day Lee disappeared
Syed tells Wilds that he's going to kill
Lee Wilds then borrows syed's car and
cell phone on the condition that Wilds
dropped Syed off at school which he does
Wilds then goes to his friend Jen
pusateri's house to hang out Syed has a
free period and then gets to a
psychology class late at 1 27 PM that
class ends at 2 15 pm and according to
Syed he goes to track practice later
from 3 30 to 4 30 or 5. up to this point
the timelines from Syed and Wilds are
largely similar but this is also where
they start to diverge substantially and
it's this Gap in time 215 to 3 30 that
the prosecution focuses on as the time
Syed kills Lee according to Wilds Syed
calls him at some point in the afternoon
asking Wilds to pick him up later not
hearing anything further from Syed Wilds
eventually leaves pusateri's house and
drives to his friend Jeff's house Jeff
wasn't home and as Wilds is leaving the
neighborhood he gets a call from Syed
asking him to meet at Best Buy it's
notable that Wilds believe this call was
around 3 30 or so both he and pusateri
remember Wilds leaving her house around
3 30. but the prosecution used a cell
phone log to argue that this phone call
from Syed de Wilds actually happened at
2 36. remember it is important to the
prosecution that the murder happens
sometime between 2 15 and 3 30.
according to Wilds he meets Syed at the
Best Buy parking lot where Syed shows
him Lee's body in the trunk of her own
car they then ditched Lee's car at the
I-70 park and ride and after buying some
marijuana Wilds dropped Syed off at
track practice Wilds later picked Syed
up from track practice Syed retrieves
Lee's car and ultimately they end up at
Lincoln Park Wilds also testifies that
syed's phone received two phone calls
while Syed was digging a hole for Lee's
body the cell phone records showed two
incoming phone calls at 709 and 7 16 on
the daily disappeared the state then
called an expert from atnt who testified
that the cell towers where the calls
were received were connected with cell
sites around Lincoln Park while this
version of events was somewhat backed up
by Pusa Terry she confirms that Wilds
was at her house until about 3 30. she
also told police that when she tried to
call Wilds on syed's phone that day
someone else answered and told her Wilds
was busy she also said that Wilds later
told her he saw Lee's body at the Best
Buy and that Syed strangled thee because
Lee broke syed's heart now something is
worth saying at this point this has been
a quick summary and is not intended to
capture all the issues identified by
people scrutinizing this case fans of
Serial are probably tearing their hair
out right now
I'm not gonna take it anymore for one
thing the version of events Wilds
testified to at trial was similar to but
not altogether consistent with his two
interviews with police Wilds himself
later told an interviewer from The
Intercept that he was terrified of going
to prison for dealing marijuana to high
school students and he was also afraid
it would somehow implicate his family
since he based his operations out of his
grandmother's house originally pusateri
told police that she didn't know
anything about what happened years later
pusateri would say that Wilds was always
very convincing he was a good
Storyteller he would make you believe
your shirt was green if it was blue when
confronted with the many versions of
wild story including one where he sees
Lee's body behind some row houses rather
than the Best Buy pusitary concluded
that Jay obviously picks and chooses
what he tells and at this point it's
created such a mess Wilde's agreed to
cooperate with the police and was
actually charged as an accessory after
the fact he told the jury that the crime
was premeditated that he heard Syed
saying I'm going to kill that [ __ ] just
hours before she disappeared he also
testified that Syed bragged about the
murder when he showed Wilds the body
saying I killed someone with my bare
hands syed's defense was that he
couldn't have committed the murder he
went to school he went to track practice
and then he went to pray at his mosque
with his father for Ramadan needless to
say a jury found him guilty of murder
robbery kidnapping and false
imprisonment and he was sentenced to
life in prison the serial podcast
presented a new witness a woman who
allegedly saw Syed at the library
between 2 30 and 2 40 on the day Lee
went missing remember the prosecution
argued that the murder had to have
happened between 2 15 and 3 30 or so the
witness Asia McLean said that she tried
to testify at syed's trial but that his
lawyer Maria Gutierrez never contacted
her it's notable that Gutierrez was
disbarred in 2001 after a series of
client complaints the podcast also
questioned the reliability of the cell
phone tower records and revealed that
physical evidence gathered in 1999 was
never tested for Mr syed's DNA in 2015
momentum from serial helped Syed file an
appeal with new lawyers a state court
granted Syed a new trial after his
lawyers showed that Gutierrez had been
grossly negligent for not calling McLean
as an alibi witness the lawyers also
questioned the reliability of the cell
tower evidence now Gutierrez had died in
2007. so she was unable to testify about
why she didn't investigate McLean in
2018 the Maryland Court of special
appeals upheld the decision to Grant
Syed a new trial and vacated his
conviction on the grounds that he
received inadequate legal assistance I
did not tell you next time you appear my
courtroom that you dress appropriately
you were serious about that the state
then appealed to Maryland's highest
court the court of appeals let's take a
step back what did Adnan Syed have to
prove to get a new trial syed's legal
team raised a claim called ineffective
assistance of counsel in violation of
the Sixth Amendment of the United States
Constitution syed's defense team
presented one issue on appeal that he
was denied effective assistance of
counsel because Gutierrez failed to even
interview The Alibi witness an alibi
witness is a defendant's claim that he
or she was at another place at the time
when the alleged crime was committed in
Strickland V Washington the U.S Supreme
Court outlined a two-prong test for
determining whether a criminal defendant
has received ineffective assistance of
counsel the defendant must first prove
that the trial council's performance was
deficient if the lawyer's performance
was deficient then the defendant has to
prove that he suffered actual Prejudice
by trial council's deficiency in other
words the defendant has to demonstrate
that if not first council's bad
performance there was a substantial
probability that the jury would not have
convicted the defendant the Maryland
court of appeals ruled against Syed in a
4-3 decision that overturned the Lower
Court ruling the court of appeals first
held that under the deficient
performance prong of Strickland V
Washington at a minimum syed's trial
Council had a duty to contact the
potential Alibi witness to investigate
or explore that person's background as a
potential as an alibi witness the
American Bar association's standard for
defense counsel required them to conduct
a prompt investigation of the
circumstances of the case and explore
all avenues leading to facts relevant to
the merits of the case and the penalty
in the event of conviction the
investigation should include efforts to
secure information in the possession of
the prosecution and law enforcement
authorities gutierrez's failure to
contact an alibi witness constituted
deficient performance under the first
prong of the Strickland test the second
prong of the Strickland test asks
whether trial council's deficient
performance resulted in and Prejudice to
show Prejudice a defendant has to show
that there is a reasonable probability
that but four council's unprofessional
errors the results of the proceeding
would have been different under this
standard a defendant must demonstrate
either one a reasonable probability that
but for council's unprofessional errors
the result of the proceeding would have
been different or two that the result of
the proceeding was fundamentally unfair
or unreliable the key question in this
analysis is what constitutes reasonable
probability the Supreme Court described
it as a probability sufficient to
undermine confidence in the outcome
Maryland courts interpret reasonable
probability to mean that there was a
substantial or significant possibility
that the verdict of the Trier effect
would have been affected
a court does not presume that the
outcome of a trial would have been
different just because the lawyer's
performance was deficient and that is
what doomed syed's appeal the court said
that even if McLean's statements about
seeing Syed in the library was true her
Alibi does little more than call into
question the time that the state claimed
Miss Lee was killed and does nothing to
rebut the evidence establishing Mr
syed's motive and opportunity to kill
Miss Lee thus the jury could have
disbelieved that Mr Syed killed Miss Lee
by 2 36 PM as the state's timeline
suggested yet still believed that Mr
Syed had the opportunity to kill Miss
Lee after 2 40 PM Miss McLean's
testimony according to her affidavit
failed to account for Mr syed's
whereabouts after 2 40 pm on January 13
1999. likewise Mr syed's statements to
the police failed to account for his
whereabouts after 2 15 PM when school
let out therefore even if The Alibi
testimony had been admitted into
evidence it could not have affected the
outcome of the case because that
evidence did not negate Mr syed's
Criminal agency so although the court
agreed that gutierrez's representation
was deficient because she had failed to
investigate an alibi witness the
majority concluded that Syed was not
prejudiced by gutierrez's mistakes the
court found that the jury would have
convicted him based on Wild's testimony
and the cell tower records as a result
Syed did not get a new trial
but that's not the end of the story
syed's claims were given New Life in
2020 after a new Maryland law gave
prosecutors the discretion to modify the
sentences of offenders who are under 18
at the time of their crimes if they had
served at least 20 years in prison in
2021 Baltimore prosecutors conducted an
investigation into the circumstances of
syed's conviction with the help of
syed's lawyers in March of 2022
Baltimore prosecutors agreed to new DNA
testing saying that it was merited
because of advances in genetic science
the prosecutor agreed to the defense
request for touch DNA testing which was
not available at the time of syed's
trial in September prosecutors filed a
motion to vacate syed's conviction Mosby
accused the State Attorney General's
office of Brady violations now the Brady
rule requires prosecutors to disclose
materially exculpatory evidence in the
government's possession to the defense
basically this means that the
prosecution has to tell the defendant
about any evidence that would
potentially negate a defendant's guilt
that would reduce the defendant's
potential sentence or evidence going to
The credibility of a witness the
prosecutor's motion said that
prosecutors on the case decades ago knew
that there was another suspect who
threatened to kill Lee and neglected to
disclose that information to defense
attorneys Mosby asked that Syed be
granted a new trial at a minimum and
released on his own personal
recognizance a local judge agreed and
Syed was freed Mosby's office then had
30 days to complete its review Maryland
attorney general Brian frosh released a
statement disputing Mosby's allegations
among the other serious problems with
the motion to vacate the allegations
related to Brady violations are
incorrect neither State's Attorney Mosby
nor anyone from her office bothered to
consult with either the assistant
State's Attorney who prosecuted the case
or with anyone in my office regarding
those alleged violations the file in
this case was made available on several
occasions to the defense the friction
between Mosby and frosh brings up
another point why would Mosby exonerate
Syed now the Maryland Supreme Court
denied syed's appeal and the U.S Supreme
Court refused to hear the case that
would have finalized his conviction
activists on both sides of the Syed case
think that the decision was politically
motivated here's to Ray McKesson who
championed syed's innocence pointing out
that Mosby has some credibility issues
of her own see here's the thing Mosby
had the new DNA evidence Allah Adnan for
a while now she didn't just get it
yesterday why was the announcement
yesterday she waited to announce to
drown out coverage of her own indictment
and here's a blog post from the
Manhattan Institute which argues against
the reforms Mosby tried to enact and
blames her for the city's skyrocketing
murder rate with the city reeling and
her reputation in tatters the safest
exit strategy for Mosby would have been
to wind down her role quietly hoping
that nobody noticed as she sculpt off to
face her federal charges instead Mosby
is reinforcing her de-prosecution
credentials executing on a plan to free
Adnan Syed convicted of killing a
teenage girl their point well Marilyn
Mosby was a lame duck you
he was one of the first prosecutors
elected on a platform of decarceration
that was in 2014. in 2022 baltimoreans
did not re-elect Mosby the federal
government indicted Mosby on two counts
of perjury and two counts of making
false statements on a loan application
the perjury counts involve Mosby
allegedly falsely claiming a covid-19
hardship on applications to withdraw
ninety thousand dollars from her
retirement account the tax-free
withdrawal option was one of the
benefits of the cares act now the
prosecutor's investigation is complete
Mosby looked at three main issues DNA
alternate suspects and cell phone
evidence Mosby said her office received
DNA testing on Lee's skirt nylons jacket
and shoes those items include
skirt pantyhose shoes and jacket of Miss
Hayman Lee forensic scientists could not
recover any DNA from the first three but
they did find a DNA mixture of multiple
contributors on Lee's shoes Mosby said
most compellingly Adnan syed's DNA was
excluded
and most compelling
Adnan Saeed
Trace level male DNA was detected on
Lee's right fingernail swabs the right
fingernail clipper swabs and the
victim's shirt swabs the swabs from the
right fingernail and shirt were then
analyzed but no useful typing results
were obtained from this analysis another
shirt swab and the right hand fingernail
clippings were not analyzed because it
was determined that the amount of male
DNA was so minimal it would not likely
produce any results with respect to
Brady material on Alternate suspects the
prosecutor's office said they found a
separate document from the original
trial file in which a different person
relayed information that can be viewed
as a motive for the same suspect to harm
the victim this information about the
threat and motives to harm could have
provided a basis for the defense and was
not disclosed to the trial nor the
post-conviction defense Council Mosby
said that new information also revealed
that one of the suspects was convicted
of attacking a woman in her vehicle and
that one of the suspects was convicted
of engaging in serial rape and sexual
assault the investigators found out that
Lee's car was located right behind the
house of one of this suspect's family
members some of this information was
available at the time of trial some of
the events occurred after the trial
according to the news release as for the
cell phone tower data the prosecutors
found that based on the cellular
technology at the time of the incident
in this case it was possible that an
incoming call could be recorded at the
last registered Tower sector and not the
current one when the signal is sent
across multiple Towers within an area
the investigative team said that two
other experts verified this conclusion
Mosby said that the investigation into
Lee's murder continues but she declined
to offer any details presumably the
investigators will look at the possible
involvement of two alternative suspects
other than Syed we don't know if the
suspects are involved individually or
involved together according to the trial
file one of these suspects said he would
make her disappear he would kill her
referring to Miss Lee
Mosby characterized syed's conviction as
a miscarriage of justice as the
administrator of the Criminal Justice
System it's my duty to ensure that
Justice is not delayed Justice is never
denied but Justice be done Lee's family
does not agree that Justice was done
they've expressed concerns about why the
Baltimore County prosecutor's office
abruptly exonerated Syed after insisting
on his guilt for decades they're very
sad I think they feel very hopeless
about any future Justice being brought
the family also felt excluded from the
prosecutor's decision making stating
that they were not informed about the
progress of the investigation on
September 29th Lee's family filed a
motion opposing syed's release asking a
court to Halt the legal proceedings to
address alleged violations of a state
victims rights law Lee's family says
that prosecutors didn't let them know
that they intended to vacate science the
motion says that two days after
prosecutors filed a motion to vacate
there was a meeting between prosecutors
and syed's attorneys the family says
they were not notified of the proceeding
and were later informed and in person
hearing was scheduled for the next
business day leaving them with no
opportunity to attend or be heard Young
Lee who's Hayes brother filed a motion
on the same day as the September hearing
stating he didn't have enough notice to
attend the court went into recess for
about 30 minutes while a call was
hastily arranged for young Lee to
express his confusion the court hasn't
ruled on the Family's motion but it's
unlikely to change the outcome Lee's
family put out a statement saying all
this family ever wanted was answers and
a voice today's actions robbed them of
both and now let me burst the True Crime
bubble Lee's family believes in syed's
guilt and they have good reasons to
there is a glaring hole in the defense
argument that McLean provided Syed with
a rock solid Alibi in his accounts of
where he went on the day Lee was killed
Syed never said that he was at the
Woodlawn Public Library McLean's
testimony conflicted with side's
accounts of his whereabouts that day
which of course made Gutierrez his
client look untruthful Gutierrez got
into trouble with the bar on other
matters but that doesn't mean that she
was wrong not to reach out to Mclean
there's another problem with the Adnan
was at the library Alibi it doesn't
account for his whereabouts after about
2 40 PM the state always asserted that
Lee was killed between 2 15 pm and 2 45
PM but they don't know for sure Syed
still had time to leave the library
strangily get Wild's help with the body
and then head back to track practice by
early evening there's yet another angle
to the McLean Story how do we know she's
telling the truth the Attorney General's
office said that two of McLean's
classmates contacted them with
allegations that she made the story up
the witnesses who are sisters remember
talking with McLean about it in their
Co-op class and I quote both my sister
and I more so my sister argued with Asia
about how serious this situation was she
just said that it wouldn't hurt anything
that if he was truly guilty then he
would be convicted I'm not sure what can
come of this information but I felt I
had to let someone know lots of people
will say that these two classmates who
remain anonymous must be the Liars but
that's the problem people tend to draw
inferences about who's telling the truth
based on which side they're rooting for
McLean apparently wasn't so sure that
her Alibi meant Syed was innocent it
seems even McLean knew that if she Syed
in the library it did not mean he
wouldn't have had time to kill Lee She
Wrote to him when he first went to
prison saying if you are innocent I will
do my best to help you but if you're not
only God can help you McLean later
published a book called Confessions of a
serial alibi
the Attorney General's office pushed
back against Mosby's claim that the
McLean information was withheld from the
defense among the other serious problems
with the motion to vacate the
allegations related to Brady violations
are incorrect the office said in a news
release issued after the hearing neither
States Attorney Mosby nor anyone else
from her office bothered to consult with
either the assistant State's Attorney
who prosecuted the case or with anyone
in my office regarding these alleged
violations the file in this case was
made available on several occasions to
the defense moreover it's worth pointing
out that the inconsistencies in wildes
accounts of what happened that day were
actually addressed head-on by the
prosecution during trial and then
there's the new touch DNA evidence it
revealed that there were multiple DNA
contributors on Lee's shoe but none of
them Syed
so what does that mean well honestly not
a lot it could mean Syed never touched
the shoe or it could mean Syed did touch
the shoe but not enough or in the right
way to transfer his DNA onto it by
itself it really doesn't mean much
so although Adnan Syed has been
exonerated by the state of Maryland the
question remains who killed Heyman Lee
back in January of 1999. was it one
suspect or two people working in concert
did investigators know their names
during syed's trial in 2000 sources say
that Baltimore County Prosecutors are
mostly considering old suspects of
course there was presumably a reason
that these suspects weren't pursued in
the original case what were those
reasons and what did the Maryland
Attorney General's office know about
them and perhaps most importantly ismos
be able to test those suspects DNA only
time will tell but Syed will be spending
that time a free man
go uh well yeah now that Adnan is out of
jail he'll probably want a delicious
home-cooked meal delivered straight to
his door which you can get with today's
sponsor hellofresh hellofresh is a great
way to eat delicious fresh food while
still being healthy in fact hellofresh
has a whole variety of calorie smart
carbs smart pescetarian and veggie
options so you can customize it how you
like too hellofresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week so you can
enjoy seasonal favorites like cowboy
turkey and black bean chili but mushroom
ravioli with kale and walnuts or sweet
corn and green pepper chowder now I'm a
do-it-yourself person and I have to say
I was initially pretty skeptical about
hellofresh I'm a pretty good cook so I
didn't think that I needed the help but
I actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes that I'd never
try on my own they usually keep
everyone's favorite meals and then
rotate new ones in all the time in fact
I usually increase the size of my
hellofresh servings so I can enjoy
leftovers for lunches and of course
everything was delivered straight to my
door so I didn't have to do any shopping
the produce actually gets to you faster
than in a grocery store so it arrives at
Peak freshness and flavor it's also
super easy to save time hellofresh cuts
out the meal planning and prep so the
recipes only take 20 to 30 minutes to
cook literally less time to cook than it
would normally take me to do the
shopping and it's also incredibly
sustainable since the ingredients are
pre-portioned there's less prep and less
wasted food the packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable or already
recycled content and hellofresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25 lower than that
of meals made from store-bought
groceries and of course it's 72 cheaper
than dining at a restaurant so if you'd
like to try hellofresh go to
hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle60 for 60 off plus free
shipping yes you can actually get 60 off
plus free shipping by clicking on the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description so go to
hellofresh.com and use the code legal
eagle60 or just click on the link below
plus click on that link really helps out
this Channel and after that click on
this playlist over here for more legal
eagle or I'll see you in court